[Música]
bueno
cuántos de vosotros hacéis compras
online utilizáis banca electrónica os
dais cuenta de la cantidad de
información personal que mandamos a la
red cuando hacemos eso esta información
incluye vuestros número de cuenta
dirección postal fecha de nacimiento de
ser expuesta a terceros esta información
podría darles la posibilidad de atacar
os robando evidentemente haciendo
operaciones no autorizadas en vuestra
cuenta usurpando vuestra identidad
etcétera qué pasa con los datos médicos
cada vez hay más comunidades autónomas
que dejan que los ciudadanos nos podamos
descargar nuestro historial médico
online pero qué pasaría si por ejemplo
la empresa que os va a contratar tuviera
acceso a vuestro historial médico o peor
aún a vuestro adn en el contexto actual
de internet con vuestros datos
personales continuamente viajando en la
red es fundamental que vayan protegidos
como protegemos la información eso se
hace mediante el cifrado o
encriptamiento que lo que hace es a
través de ciertos procesos hacemos que
esa información sea ininteligible no
entendible no accesible para
era ajeno a la información normalmente
lo que se hace se mezcla el texto en
claro con una clave y devuelve el texto
cifrado un ejemplo muy sencillo
imaginad que quereis cifrar ese texto
alguna secuencia binaria el lenguaje de
los ordenadores vamos a utilizar una
clave y el método el algoritmo es una
simple suma binaria pitt a bit ahí
tendríamos nuestro texto cifrado la
persona que recibe esa información tiene
que descifrar la que hace vuelva a sumar
la clave y está bien pero esta vez con
el texto cifrado y así volvemos a tener
el texto en claro
este cifrado que es bastante sencillo de
realizar si la clave cumple una serie de
condiciones que son que sea tan larga
como el mensaje puramente aleatoria y
utilizada una vez es un cifrado
irrompible es 100% seguro desde un punto
de vista matemático por eso se denomina
el secreto perfecto fue inventado en
1917 por gilbert bernand sin embargo si
os dais cuenta la persona que cifra y
descifra necesita poseer de antemano una
clave por lo tanto si dos personas que
se quieren comunicar y mandarse un
secreto tienen que previamente tener a
haberse comunicado una clave secreta
esto parece un círculo vicioso
históricamente como se solucionaba pues
entregaba físicamente las claves en mano
el alto mando alemán en la segunda
guerra mundial distribuía las claves
para la máquina enigma sabréis que es la
clave que se utilizaba el ejército
alemán para comunicarse las distribuidas
mensualmente con todas las claves
diarias que el ejército iba a necesitar
os podéis imaginar que esto conlleva un
gran problema logístico sobre todo en el
caso de los submarinos que pasaban
largas temporadas fuera
puerto
los bancos en los años 70 intentaron
mandar físicamente las claves a sus
clientes mediante mensajeros seguros
pero pronto se dieron cuenta que cuando
el número empezó a aumentar de clientes
de cristal a logísticamente imposible
imaginaros ahora en el contexto de
internet en el que los usuarios cuentan
por miles de millones sería un problema
inabarcable este problema se conoce como
el problema de distribución de la clave
y en los años 70 después de 2.000 años
de historia sin haberse resuelto había
un cierto escepticismo en la comunidad
criptográfica de que realmente tuviera
solución
pero gracias a la perseverancia de tres
hombres
difícil man y merkel en el año 1976 se
logra lo que se considera el mayor hito
de la criptografía moderna y se inventa
lo que se conoce como criptografía
asimétrica esta criptografía utiliza dos
claves una para cifrar y otra para
descifrar a diferencia de la que os
enseñado antes
la clave cifrado se denomina clave
pública y es accesible a todo el mundo y
la clave privada sólo la tiene una
persona de manera que si a list quieren
mandar un mensaje a bob al isi box se
consideran el emisor y receptor del
mensaje en criptografía tiene que
una de sus claves que está disponible
públicamente por ejemplo en un
repositorio cifras un mensaje y voz
utiliza su clave privada para
descifrarlo esto se suele ver
simbólicamente con un candado para la
clave pública y una llave para la clave
privada de manera que todos podemos
los candados de alguien mandar la
información secreta cerramos candado lo
enviamos y solo la persona destinataria
tiene la llave la clave privada para
abrir el candado
cómo se logra esto matemáticamente se
hace con funciones que se denominan
unidireccionales quiere decir que son
fáciles de hacer en un sentido cifrar
cerrar candado pero son difíciles de
invertir que sería abrir el candado si
sin la información de la clave privada
que es la llave una de estas funciones
es la factorización de un número en sus
factores primos y en esta operación se
basa el algoritmo de cifrado simétrico
más utilizado actualmente que se nomina
rsa de manera muy simplificada la clave
pública es n y es el resultado de
multiplicar dos números primos de tal
manera que si en es lo suficientemente
grande encontrar p y q es muy difícil
para los ordenadores puesto que no hay
una manera fácil de factorizar va a
probar todos los vehículos posibles y
esto es computacionalmente lento lo que
os hagáis una idea de los números n de
las claves que se utilizan actualmente
por rsa esta sería la longitud del
número n para una clave de 2 mil 64 bits
son 600 17 cifras decimales es seguro
rsa actualmente cifra información
militar
diplomática podemos confiar en su
seguridad en el futuro para romper rsa
hay que encontrar vehículo de manera
rápida los avances en computación hacen
que se duplique la capacidad para
computar cada 18 meses pero esto no es
suficiente necesitamos hacerlo mucho más
rápido los matemáticos llevaban siglos
intentando encontrar un atajo para
factorizar sin éxito sin embargo un
matemático salió de su zona de confort y
miró el problema desde otro punto de
vista
aplicó la mecánica cuántica en el año
1994 y tensor encontró el único
algoritmo de factorización que es capaz
de factorizar en un tiempo polinómica en
lugar de especial qué quiere decir esto
quiere decir en esa curva ves el tiempo
que tardaría en factorizar un ordenador
respecto a la longitud de la clave si
veis la curva que sube eso es lo que
tengo un ordenador clásico la curva más
baja es un ordenador cuántico de tal
manera que para cualquier número n veis
que los tiempos son bastante diferentes
y lo peor es que cuando sube n
la diferencia entre esos tiempos es
mucho mayor esto que implica implica que
erre sea estar rota pero en que basa el
ordenador cuántico esos principios esos
principios de los que os he hablado
antes cuáles son el primero se llama
superposición cuántica 1 sistema
cuántico es capaz de estar en múltiples
estados simultáneamente a diferencia de
un bit clásico que puede estar en cero o
en uno un bit cuántico o cubit puede
estar en cero y uno a la vez esto quiere
decir que con unos cuantos qubits puedes
mapear un número de soluciones posible
que escala como 2 elevado al número de
qubits por lo tanto puedes probar
muchísimas más combinaciones que en el
caso de un ordenador clásico en este
caso las probabilidades pq los pares p y
q que solucionan tu problema por otro
lado el entrelazamiento cuántico en el
tratamiento cuántico es la propiedad que
tienen partículas de hablarse entre sí
aunque estén separadas a una distancia
física es como si tuvieran telepatía
el ordenador cuántico utiliza esa
propiedad para que los qubits hablen
entre sí y procese todavía más
eficientemente en el momento que se
publicó el algoritmo de sort los años 90
nadie pensaba que se iba a construir un
ordenador cuántico y no hubo demasiada
preocupación sin embargo hoy en día en
los últimos años especialmente los
últimos cinco años empresas como google
ibm microsoft e intel están haciendo
unos avances enormes en computación
cuántica tanto que instituciones
internacionales como el nist el
instituto de tecnologías y estándares
americanos ha recomendado a las empresas
y a los centros públicos que vayan
cambiando ya sus protocolos
criptográficos a aquellos que sean
resistentes al ordenador cuántico ellos
piensan que va a estar aquí un ordenador
cuántico capaz de amenazar la asegura de
la información en aproximadamente 10
años que hacemos
hay que buscar evidentemente una manera
alternativa de cifrar la información os
he dicho antes que había un secreto
perfecto el cifrado de secreto perfecto
pero necesita una clave necesita
destruir una clave de manera segura cómo
hacemos esto de manera que sea segura
ante un ordenador cuántico quizá
buceando en la cuántica podamos resolver
un problema que la misma cuántica ha
creado
uno de los principios en el corazón de
la mecánica cuántica es el principio
incertidumbre de heisenberg no sé si los
estudiantes en el colegio pero en este
principio nos dicen que no es posible
medir dos variables a la vez en el mundo
cuántico siempre una partícula como un
electrón si queremos medir su posición y
velocidad podemos hacerle incidir una
luz y ver su reflejo pero cuando hacemos
esto la mínima cantidad de luz que
podemos mandar es un fotón cuando llega
al electrón choca contra él como si
fuera una bola de billar que transfiere
energía y entonces electrón cambia de
velocidad por lo tanto la misma medida
está cambiando el estado de la medida
entonces existe una excepción break y
esto no sólo aplica posición y velocidad
aplica a otras muchas magnitudes una de
ellas es la polarización de fotones
individuales que es la polarización es
la manera que tiene de girar la luz
puede girar en todas las direcciones del
espacio vertical horizontal diagonal la
luz es así
entonces como la medimos la podemos
medir con un polarizador que es una
lámina un filtro que sólo deja pasar una
dirección de polarización bien si ahora
tenemos un fotón verticalmente
polarizado que incide sobre un
polarizador diagonal que está a 45
grados esto forma un principio
incertidumbre también de manera que el
fotón lo que puede hacer es en un 50% de
probabilidad se va a absorber y en otro
50% de probabilidad va a pasar pero va a
cambiar su polarización es en este
cambio en el que se basaron charles
benet y giles lassad entonces en ibm en
el año 1984 para formular el principio
de distribución de clave cuántica bebé
84 y sin entrar en muchos detalles os
diré que el protocolo se basa en la
transmisión de fotones individuales con
esos estados de polarización que tiene
alice y va a ir midiendo en dos bases en
dos canales de tal manera que son
capaces de compartir una secuencia
binaria sin errores
a menos que haya habido un espía en el
canal porque el espía va a generar un
error y va a cambiar ciertos estados de
unos a ceros y viceversa y entonces al
isi vo podrán detectarlo es la primera
vez que se logra distribuir una clave en
el que la seguridad se puede verificar
de tal manera que si no ha sido seguro
el protocolo de distribución de clave
esa clave se deseche se empieza de nuevo
esta seguridad es absoluta en términos
de la shura de la información no depende
de la capacidad computacional de un
ordenador cuántico porque se basa en los
mismos principios de la física cuántica
y ahora con esa clave que tenemos que
hacemos pues ahora la metemos en el
cifrado que os conté al principio que
necesitaba una clave segura y aleatoria
ya la tenemos podríamos decir que es el
secreto perfecto y además resistente al
ordenador cuántico también podemos
mandar partículas entrelazadas para
distribuir una clave de tal manera que
las partículas entrelazadas viajan en
superposición de dos estados de
polarización es como si tiraremos dos
monedas a dos extremos del mundo que
están girando una nueva york cuando la
mides acá en cara y eso hace que la que
está en tokio sin haberla tocado cambie
y se ponga en cruz vale están definidas
siempre con sentidos opuestos y hay como
una correlación entre ellas que no se
sabe explicar pero es así esta propiedad
se puede utilizar de tal manera que en
vez de cara digamos la polarización
sería horizontal con lo que podemos
codificar el estado cero
y obtendría el 1 siguen tirando las
monedas y aparece el estado vertical que
codifica el 1 y por lo tanto obtiene un
cero y así vas repitiendo al final de la
transmisión bo cambia a sus unos por
ceros y sus ceros por unos y han
compartido una secuencia
cuál es el estado de esta tecnología
actualmente la distribución cuántica de
clave necesita fotones individuales que
se pueden lograr con atenuando un láser
y detectar esos fotones de manera
individual
hay también detectores comerciales que
logran esto se ha probado enlaces de
fibra óptica en enlaces aéreos
sin embargo se enfrenta a ciertos retos
tecnológicos al ser una señal tan
atenuada los fotones individuales pues
son vulnerables al ruido y a la
absorción aún así se ha logrado en el
año 2017 la transmisión de una clave
cuántica desde un satélite a dos puntos
en la tierra a 1.200 kilómetros se ha
logrado china por otro lado la unión
europea acaba de firmar un acuerdo en el
que varios países entre ellos españa se
compromete a instalar una
infraestructura que conecte a varias
ciudades europeas con distribución
cuántica de clave tanto fibra óptica
como espacio libre para proteger a
europa a nuestra economía de
ciberamenazas y por último os voy a
dejar una idea más futurista pero que ya
hay muchos laboratorios que están
trabajando en ella se llama el internet
cuántico sería una red en la que los
nodos serían computadores cuánticos vale
y se intercambien información mediante
canales ultra seguros que proporcionaría
la distribución cuántica de clave este
internet no va a sustituir al actual al
no necesitamos un internet cuántico para
mirar nuestras redes sociales
pero si sería una herramienta que podría
permitir la distribución segura de
información muy sensible como secretos
de seguridad nacional información de los
usuarios muy privada como los datos del
genoma etcétera lo que sí está claro es
que estamos viviendo un cambio de
paradigma en el que no solo
las comunicaciones y la computación está
cambiando sino otros campos como los
sensores la simulación cuántica esto nos
permite por ejemplo simular la realidad
a nivel molecular lo que nos va a
permitir desarrollar nuevos medicamentos
nuevos tratamientos médicos más
eficientes simular el clima de manera
más eficiente
y todo esto todos estos avances se
enmarcan dentro de lo que ya se llama la
segunda revolución cuántica estáis
preparados
[Aplausos]
[Música]